almost two years ago i posted a video on
the six reasons why i quit social media
and with the exception of youtube it's
hard to believe that it will soon be
almost seven years that i decided to
delete my facebook account and go
without any accounts such as twitter
instagram tock to quit social media for
good in my previous video i shared about
my addiction to social media and how i
lived for the likes and posting that
perfect photo instead of living in the
present moment the fomo that i
experienced and the negative side
effects that it had on me such as
insecurity comparison and just an
overall feeling of anxiety and
inadequacy and so today i want to share
with you how my decision to quit social
media has changed my life dramatically
as a millennial soon graduating from
college everyone i knew had social media
all of my classmates were on facebook
and had facebook groups even my teachers
and instagram was just starting to blow
up i've gotten some comments saying that
quitting social media is trendy and that
may be the case now and i'm glad that
there's an awareness about this issue
but it was definitely not the trend at
the time i was definitely regarded as
the weirdo the odd one out and that some
of my classmates thought was just a
loser who probably didn't have any
friends or a social life that was worth
posting about and in the beginning
especially my classmate's perceptions of
me was of huge importance to me and it
began to instill doubt in me maybe i was
the loner loser with no social life
maybe my life was too boring too
pointless to post about
maybe they were right
at that stage of my life i had not
realized that i was going through
withdrawal for years i had allowed
myself to be programmed to instantly
reach for my phone and snap a photo of
something and post it the moment
something interesting happened or to
check my notifications the moment i had
just even one or two minutes of idle
time i had lost the ability to be still
be quiet and be present
and as dr cal newport puts it i had lost
my intellectual independence and the
worst part is i gave it up willingly to
a device that took up hours of my day
for something that only left me feeling
empty i've been told that it's pointless
to leave social media if you're going to
swap it out for the next bad habit like
binge watching netflix day in and day
out and i was actually very aware of
that i had reached a point in my life
when i felt so empty i questioned what i
was doing with my life and what the
point of it all was
i made my decision to quit social media
because
i was tired of living a superficial life
i was tired of pretending to be this
happy carefree 20-something-year-old
when in reality i struggled with social
anxiety to the degree that i would start
sweating my heart would start racing if
i even had to call someone over the
phone instead of via text and that i
struggled daily with self-loathing and
self-doubt and i decided that if i was
going to quit social media cold turkey
that to make it easier for myself i was
going to replace it with things that
would make me happier and that is where
the first major change comes in
i have a question for you on a scale of
0 to 10 how would you rate your social
interactions this can be something you
just think of in your own mind or you
can post it in the comments and we can
chat about it together but do think
about it i have a video where i talk
more about my journey with social
anxiety and what i specifically did to
beat the struggle that i had it was
around this time that i realized that i
had to change and i came across vanessa
van edwards and i started to apply a lot
of the lessons that she teaches i began
to force myself to go out because it
made me anxious i forced myself to lead
events initiate conversations and even
make eye contact with the person in the
elevator and smile and something amazing
happened i began to have more meaningful
and deeper conversations with my friends
and family and even perfect strangers
and i began to crave that and want more
of those deeper conversations and my
focus completely shifted from what will
people think of me to
how can i make this person feel valuable
how can i make them feel that they
matter and when my mindset shifted from
worrying about whether or not people
would like me to focus on liking other
people i now had the ability to love
other people and genuinely see them the
way that i had wanted to be seen and it
felt like freedom
[Music]
i have another question for you who are
you investing in i know that when i had
social media i spent hours upon hours
following the lives of my friends and
celebrities admiring their lives and
wishing that mine could be more
glamorous when i left those sites i
found myself with time i had time to sit
quietly with myself and ask who am i
what do i want from my life what do i
want to leave behind when i die i
realized that i had been so focused on
keeping up with the kardashians and
investing my time in them and in other
people that i wasn't investing in myself
and so i took this time and i began to
go out in nature more go on hikes and
exercise and i also started to eat
better i started to listen to audiobooks
on my commutes and i changed the way
that i consumed content i stopped
watching tv and then later on we
actually ended up getting rid of our tv
all together i did mention that youtube
is the account that i did decide to keep
and i found myself with a much greater
awareness of the value of my time i
could no longer just sit through
watching funny videos vlogs or just
videos that were meant to entertain i
instead began to use it to search for
content that would help me learn
something new or improve my life in some
way and as all of these sorts of things
slowly started changing little by little
i found myself perceiving myself
differently i was more forgiving of
myself i was more open to trying new
things to experimenting and making
mistakes and i found myself with a spark
of creativity and this is where
everything changed for me
do you want to be a consumer or a
producer when i began to place greater
value in my social interactions and
value other people i began to have a
greater value for myself i began to see
that i had something that was worth
sharing and it was this change in me
that gave me permission to be creative i
was in a live play with an audience of
over 1500 people and i began to explore
the idea that maybe i wasn't meant to
sit and watch the play
maybe i was meant to be in the play and
this metaphorical play is life i no
longer wanted life to happen to me i
wanted to live my life with intention
by now many of us know that social media
is designed to be addictive after all
the very people who design casinos work
diligently to make sure that you stay
glued to your device as long as possible
but i also don't think that social media
is evil i have no doubt that social
media can be helpful and many
individuals make a living off of social
media others buy or sell through it or
even have support groups that otherwise
wouldn't be available to them in person
but when it comes to the way you use
social media it can go either two ways
either you're using it or it's using you
and that decision is yours alone to make
do you want to sit and watch the play or
do you want to be in the play you get to
decide
i thank you so much for watching if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and subscribe so that you won't miss
when i post a new video i can't wait to
hear from you in the comments and see
you in the next video bye for now
[Music]
you